this video is brought to you by policy
genius if you have family members who
depend on your income you need life
insurance that's where policy genius
comes in
more on them in just a
bit after the victory over the british
in the revolutionary war the newly
independent united states of america
found itself in a position to build a
new nation from the ground up but that
left some pressing questions how would
this nation be governed how much power
should be allocated to the federal
government and how much should be
allocated to the individual states and
how could this new country ensure that
its citizens would prosper economically
at the center of all three of these
questions was alexander hamilton who
came from the humblest backgrounds to
rise to the very upper echelons of the
new american government in doing so he
became one of the most impactful and
controversial public servants the united
states has ever had everything about his
life seemed scripted for dramatic
purposes including his vile and death at
the hands of one of his political
opponents and beyond political
historians and musical theater fans few
people know anything about alexander
hamilton beyond the fact that his face
adorns the 10 bill we hope to change
that today and let you decide if
hamilton was a prophet who successfully
predicted america's future rise or like
his opponents charged that he was satan
incarnate drawing his new country down
the path of damnation
we know very little about alexander
hamilton's childhood because he rarely
talked about it from what we do know it
isn't hard to see why he was born on the
11th of january
1757 on the island of nevis in the
british west indies because his parents
weren't married he was declared
illegitimate a label that would follow
him all of his life and would normally
have greatly impacted his standing in
society things got even worse when
alexander's father james hamilton
abandoned the family when he was a child
and soon after his mother rachel died of
yellow fever rachel's jealous husband
johan lavian seized every penny of her
estate leaving alexander and his brother
james jr impoverished orphans the only
thing alexander had going for him was
his exceptional intelligence he was an
avid reader and despite receiving little
formal education quickly figured out the
merchant's trade when employed as a
clerk for an import export firm in the
islands in 1772 the 15 year old hamilton
wrote a letter to his father describing
a hurricane that had struck the
caribbean that was so well written that
it was published in the newspaper and
community leaders took up a collection
to send this exceptional boy to north
america to be educated probably hoping
that hamilton would return to the
islands to practice a skilled trade such
as doctoral lawyer if that was their
hope it was in vain alexander hamilton
left the west indies in the fall of 1772
and never returned he never saw his
father or his brother again after a year
at prep school in new jersey hamilton
enrolled at king's college in new york
city today columbia university he wanted
to become a lawyer something that suited
his talent for oral and written argument
well but like everyone else in america
he soon found himself caught up in the
convulsions that would reverberate
across the continent and eventually the
world
hamilton had thrown himself
wholeheartedly into the patriot cause
early on writing passionate essays under
pen names they were published in the
winter of 1774-1775
when torque devolved into war in the
spring of 1775 hamilton like many young
men volunteered for service in the
various militia companies that would
soon be fashioned into the continental
army hamilton became captain of an
artillery company and saw action against
the british in the campaigns around new
york city which the british occupied
after a successful invasion in july 1776
hamilton's talent soon attracted the
attention of continental army commander
george washington who promoted him to
lieutenant colonel and appointed him as
his chief of staff in early 1777. as a
member of washington's military family
he was far more than a mere aide in many
respects hamilton was washington's
right-hand man drafting orders and
letters on behalf of the
commander-in-chief negotiating with the
continental congress and senior army
commanders on his behalf and becoming
involved in detailed matters of
diplomacy intelligence supply and
logistics and everything else needed to
keep an army in the field it was the
start of a relationship that would
persist for the rest of their lives
washington who had no biological
children probably viewed the young
hamilton as someone he could mentor as a
paternal figure while hamilton who had
latched on to surrogate fathers
throughout his life saw a man he could
emulate and admire the relationship
between the two men would in the coming
decades shaped the course of american
history hamilton spent four years as
washington's chief of staff becoming
well known throughout the army as
washington's man but hamilton was a
young man with the young man's thirst
for glory and he desperately wanted a
field command he finally got one in
august 1781 just in time to participate
in the most important battle of the
revolutionary war washington's army in
conjunction with america's french allies
had surrounded the british army of lord
cornwallis in yorktown virginia to
complete their encirclement of
cornwallis's position two small forts
known as redoubts 9 and 10 needed to be
seized colonel hamilton was named
commander of the american effort to
recapture redoubt number 10 while the
french seized number nine in a nighttime
action on october the 14th 400 american
soldiers led by hamilton stormed the
redoubt a bare net point capturing the
position after heavy hand-to-hand
fighting with the french also succeeding
in capturing their target cornwallis
fate was sealed five days later eight
thousand soldiers marched out of
yorktown having surrendered to the
americans and the french even though new
york would be occupied by the british
until 1783 for all intents and purposes
the war was over and america had won her
independence
[Music]
alexander hamilton returned to new york
city and finished his legal training in
july 1782. he plunged into legal work
with the same energy he put into
everything else quickly becoming one of
new york's most prominent attorneys he
also raised a large family with his wife
eliza eventually the couple would have
eight children between 1782 and 1802 but
hamilton had turned his eye toward a new
passion by then
politics in the 1780s the new nation won
by blood shed by men like hamilton was
in crisis the united states was governed
by a document known as the articles of
confederation under the articles the
federal government was incredibly weak
only being able to act with the consent
of all 13 states and since the states
never seemed to agree on anything
nothing was getting done there was no
way to mitigate disputes between states
who at times acted like independent
countries onto themselves and if things
continued the way they were then it was
just a matter of time before the country
tore itself apart hamilton served in the
congress of the confederation and knew
exactly how poor it was he joined a
growing chorus of politicians who called
for the articles to be replaced in may
1787 hamilton was chosen as one of three
representatives from new york to the
constitutional convention in
philadelphia hamilton's influence at the
convention was limited by the two other
new york delegates who belonged to a
faction controlled by new york governor
george clinton that was opposed to any
reform that would take power away from
his state despite this the other
delegates headed by convention president
george washington hammered out a brand
new united states constitution over the
course of four months that created a new
federal government made up of an elected
president and a congress who would make
laws that covered all the states but the
new constitution would only go into
effect if nine of the 13 states ratified
it in state conventions something that
wasn't guaranteed hamilton wanted to
help convince the american people that
the new constitution was not only
necessary but it benefited them then
they would put pressure on their
legislators to ratify it hamilton
enlisted the help of two other
passionate supporters of the
constitution fellow new yorker john jay
and virginian james madison and they
would write a series of articles
explaining it to the public written
under the pseudonym publius the series
of 85 articles was published in major
newspapers between october 1787 and
april 1788. the federalist papers as
they are known today explained in
painstaking detail all of the flaws of
the articles of confederation as well as
an in-depth explanation of each article
of the new constitution including how it
benefited the average american citizen
the federalist papers were an immediate
sensation being widely read across the
country and eventually published in a
two-volume book in 1788 the barrage of
well-written and explained arguments in
favor of the constitution overwhelmed
any opposition the people began to
clamor for their state legislatures to
adopt the new document on june 21 1788
new hampshire became the ninth state to
ratify the constitution officially
putting it into effect one month later
hamilton's home state of new york
finally ratified it rather than risk
being left out of the union of the other
states though the identity of publius
was officially a secret most everyone
knew that alexander hamilton was one of
the principal authors of the federalist
papers and he would be closely
associated with the strong central
government laid out in the constitution
for the rest of his life now just before
we continue with today's video a quick
word from today's wonderful sponsor
policy genius look no one likes to think
about life insurance because it means
that you're going to be thinking about
death but the reality is that it's an
important layer of protection for many
families especially single-income
households fortunately this policy
genius and their award-winning policy
options ranked number one by forbes
whether you've been putting off your
purchase or just never really thought
about it policy genius is the team that
you want to check in with this is a
third-party marketplace that works for
you not for the insurance company so you
can trust that their licensed experts
are going to give you solid unbiased
advice life insurance premiums might
seem like a financial drain but you
could save 1
300 or more per year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies if you're interested head to
policygenius.com to get started and in
just a few minutes you can work out how
much coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team or handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
you could save 50 or more in life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius and getting covered now
locks in your rate over the course of a
10 or 20-year policy those savings
really do add up and best of all
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week so head to
policygenius.com to get started you'll
be glad you did because when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right and
now back to today's video
[Music]
on april 30 1789 george washington took
the oath of office as the first
president of the united states having
been universally elected by the
electoral college the constitution did
not specify how the executive branch of
government of which the revolutionary
war hero was now the head was to conduct
its business leaving washington to
construct the apparatus of governments
around him he decided to ask congress to
create three new government departments
state war and treasury the secretaries
of these departments appointed by the
president and confirmed by the senate
would together with the attorney general
formed the cabinet a group of men who
would oversee the everyday business of
executive government and advise the
president on policy matters almost 250
years later this is still how the
executive branch functions though
today's cabinet is made up of 25 members
instead of four washington's trusted
wartime aide decarb alexander hamilton
was selected by the president to serve
as the first secretary of the treasury
the department that was to oversee the
fledgling country's fragile economy
confirmed by the senate in september
hamilton immediately got to work with
his usual gusto the first problem was
the biggest the government had no money
to pay for its business the entire
country suffered from a lack of ready
cash and the obvious solution was to
borrow money but with no established
credit rating none of the large european
banks were willing to give the united
states government a loan to resolve this
hamilton proposed to create a public
debt using debts incurred by the various
states during the revolutionary war
which the federal government would
assume if he could show the u.s could
pay back its internal debt then foreign
banks would feel confident that it could
pay back any international debts
incurred in addition the bonds could be
traded by speculators known as stock
jabbers as currency which would
stimulate the american economy hamilton
ran into unexpectedly fierce opposition
from a group of political figures headed
by the newly appointed secretary of
state thomas jefferson jefferson had
been involved with the american
experiment from the beginning he was the
principal author of the declaration of
independence but jefferson was skeptical
of the constitution and mistrusted a
strong federal government taking on a
public debt increased the power of the
federal government and opened the door
to possible corruption which jefferson
associated with tyrannical rule
president washington wanted both men in
his cabinet as he believed both would
offer valuable service to the new
government he encouraged them to find a
compromise and there was something
jefferson's faction wanted the federal
capital it was currently located in new
york city but southern politicians like
jefferson wanted it moved further south
closer to their states a deal was struck
the capital would be moved first to
philadelphia and then eventually to a
planned federal site on the potomac
river that formed the border between
maryland and virginia in exchange the
revolutionary war dead would be assumed
by the federal government hamilton was a
new yorker at heart and he knew losing
the capital would hurt his home city but
he also knew it was what was best for
the country as a whole so he agreed and
so it was that washington dc was born
and the foundation of the american
economy was laid
the deal between hamilton and jefferson
over the capital was the last time the
two founding fathers were able to work
together on anything the two men were
fairly similar to each other and in
another life they could have probably
been close friends but both men were
stubbornly committed to their principles
believing the future of the nation was
at stake and they both had wildly
different ideas about what direction the
united states should take jefferson a
plantation owner who owned hundreds of
slaves believed that a largely agrarian
nation populated by small-holding
farmers was the most democratic form for
an economy to take in foreign policy he
favored france believing the upheavals
of the french revolution were a
continuation of the american struggle to
overthrow monarchy most importantly he
favored a weak federal government that
was subordinate to the whims of state
government particularly large ones like
virginia he and his supporters like
hamilton's collaborator on the
federalist papers james madison formed a
faction they called democratic
republicans today historians refer to
them as the jeffersonian republicans to
differentiate them from the modern
democratic and republican parties
alexander hamilton by contrast believed
the future of america lay not in farming
but in commerce through manufacturing
and trade because 90 percent of american
trade at the time came through great
britain hamilton favored them not
because he wanted to restore british
rule in america but because he believed
it benefited his nation economically and
he believed that the best way to govern
the country was through a strong federal
government with broad authority he and
his faction were called federalists
george washington was officially neutral
not belonging to either of the two
factions in fact he cautioned against
forming political parties at all
believing they would lead to the
downfall of the republic but he was
unable to keep members of the cabinet
from gearing up for an all-out assault
on each other their weapon of choice was
the country's newspapers newspapers of
the period contained very little
objective reporting instead they were a
vehicle for partisan writers to exhort
their cause and to attack their
opponents through a series of long
opinion pieces most of these were
written under pen names but everybody
knew who the authors were on the
federalist side this was frequently
alexander hamilton where jefferson
preferred to avoid direct confrontation
and used proxies all the while hamilton
continued to work moulding the american
economy into his vision he founded a
national bank established a u.s mint in
philadelphia to produce currency formed
the u.s coast guard to prevent smuggling
a big problem when most of the
government's money came from customs
duties and worked to expand domestic
manufacturing and to end the country's
over alliance and foreign imports
washington generally sided with hamilton
in disputes between his treasury and
state secretary something that incensed
jefferson to the point that he resigned
as post at the end of 1793. by now
jefferson was convinced that not only
was hamilton taking the country down the
wrong path but that he was actively
corrupt probably enriching himself
either through stock jobbing or through
secret deals with the british the
attacks in hamilton's policies turned
increasingly personal portraying him as
an evil shadow lurking behind the chair
of the noble washington some of the more
vicious attacks criticized his foreign
origins and even his illegitimacy all of
this weighed heavily on hamilton he felt
underappreciated he was also heavily in
debt and able to support his family on
his government salary certainly there
was no hidden fortune derived from
corruption finally on january 31 1795
hamilton resigned as treasury secretary
returning to private life
in 1796 george washington decided not to
run for a third term as president
wanting to avoid the perception that it
was a post that one person should hold
for life washington's magnaminity set up
the first competitive election in the
country's history the logical choice for
hamilton and the federalists was to
support the vice president john adams
believing him to be the only person who
could defeat thomas jefferson something
that was proved out when adams was
elected president but john adams was no
george washington adams has spent
decades in public service having
collaborated with jefferson on the
declaration of independence and serving
as foreign ambassador to the courts of
europe but in all that time adams had
never developed the thick skin needed to
work in politics he took even the
smallest slide personally and held
grudges for a long time he spent months
at a time outside of the capital in his
home of massachusetts dictating his
orders via letters and most importantly
for hamilton adams wanted nothing to do
with him scorning his advice hamilton
chafed at the loss of influence and
looked for a way to get back into the
action revolutionary france provided him
with that opportunity the united states
had concluded a trade deal with great
britain a few years earlier the
controversial j treaty the french who
were at war with britain viewed this as
a betrayal and a series of diplomatic
skirmishes threatened to descend into
war president adams felt he had no
choice but to raise an army to defend
the country in the face of a possible
french invasion a natural choice to
command this army was george washington
but washington would only accept the
command if his second in command was
alexander hamilton so hamilton was
appointed a major general in 1798 with
washington ailing at his home in mount
vernon hamilton effectively ran the army
taking charge of training organization
and supplies adams didn't want war with
france or anyone else pinning his hopes
on a diplomatic solution this brought
him into conflict with hamilton who
still clung to boyish notions of
military glory everything started to go
wrong for hamilton at once his great
friend and patron george washington died
in 1799. adams stripped funding for the
army privately worrying that hamilton
wanted to march on the capitol and set
himself up as a dictator america's first
political sex scandal came to light as
newspaper reports revealed the spicy
details of an affair hamilton had in
1792 with a woman named maria reynolds
who it appeared was extorting him for
money to keep the affair a secret
hamilton in a bizarre display decided to
admit to the affair in a published
pamphlet that was widely circulated
hamilton wanted to defend himself from
corruption charges but the pamphlet just
made things worse things came to a head
in 1800 when hamilton furious at john
adams for dismantling his army after a
peace deal with napoleon was reached
turned his pen on the president
attacking his fitness for office and
endorsing a south carolina federalist
charles pickney instead many people
privately agreed with hamilton about
adams character but the attack on adam
split the federalist vote ensuring the
election of hamilton's greatest rival
jefferson to the highest office adams
never forgave hamilton and spent the
rest of his life attacking hamilton's
character in print as for hamilton the
political blunders seemed to have
destroyed his own career which probably
prevented him from having any chance of
running for president himself
[Music]
in 1804 vice president aaron burr was a
man with no friends in the election of
1800 he had been the jeffersonian
candidate for vice president by the way
the constitution was originally written
whoever got the most electoral votes
became president and the runner-up
became vice president the problem with
this came when the top two candidates in
this case jefferson and burr tied in the
electoral vote throwing the election to
the house of representatives burr was a
political opportunist and used the tie
votes to try and gain the office for
himself at the expense of jefferson
courting disgruntled federalists to try
and vote for him instead this didn't
work and the newly elected vice
president found himself shut out of
jefferson's government everyone knew
that when jefferson came up for
re-election in 1804 burr was going to be
dropped from the ticket burr decided
that his next move was to run for
governor of his home state of new york
hoping to build a following there for a
possible return to washington but what
was left of alexander hamilton's power
base was in new york and if there was
one man hamilton didn't want him power
it was aaron burr hamilton believed that
burr only cared about himself and that
he had no principles except whatever
would ensure his own advancement he
disliked burst so much that he
campaigned in the house for jefferson
and the 1800 thai election a strange
irony
that was not lost to hamilton in 1804
hamilton campaigned to hard for burr's
opponent morgan lewis playing a key role
in his victory in that race burr hadn't
forgotten hamilton's politicking in 1800
and felt that this was the second time
the former secretary of the treasury had
derailed his political ambitions he
challenged hamilton to a pistol duel
duels or affairs of honor were holdovers
from the days of chivalry a form of
ritualized murder in which the two
combatants stood 20 paces apart and shot
at each other people dying in duels was
relatively rare it was more about
demonstrating their bravery and being
willing to face down death in the name
of honor in that way it was more a show
of political grandstanding than anything
else burr wanted to try and use a
showdown with hamilton to resurrect his
failing political career and hamilton
never wanted to back down from a
challenge happily obliged him hamilton
let it be known in the days preceding
the duel that he had no intention of
trying to kill burr he intended to throw
away his shot by firing his gun in the
air a demonstration that he held no
ill-will towards his opponent many such
duels ended this way with both
combatants walking away unscathed their
personal honor intact dueling was
illegal in new york so the two men met
across the river in new jersey on the
morning of july the 11th 1804. in an
ironic twist of fate it was the same
spot where two years earlier hamilton's
eldest son philip had been killed in a
duel himself hamilton probably fired
first and his shot missed probably on
purpose burst shot did not miss the
bullet struck hamilton in the abdomen
doing major damage to his internal
organs and lodging in his spine hamilton
knew immediately that he'd been mortally
wounded he was taken back to his home in
new york where he lasted until the next
day saying goodbye to his distraught
wife and children as well as his friends
he was only 49 when the bullet finally
claimed his life
the death of alexander hamilton proved
to be the death now for the federalist
party that he led jeppesen's party now
held unchallenged ascendancy as
jeffersonian republicans held the
presidency from 1800 to 1824 but
hamilton's financial system which
jefferson hated so much survived because
as jefferson's treasury secretary albert
gallatin pointed out the system was so
perfectly constructed any attempt to
dismantle it would harm the country in
fact when president james madison
allowed the first bank of the united
states to expire during his
administration it precipitated a
financial crisis that forced him to
sheepishly found the second bank of the
united states to restore american
finance hamilton's death also killed the
political career of aaron burr though he
escaped murder charges filed against him
he never held another office after his
term as vice president ended in 1805. he
spent the rest of his life moving from
place to place as a pariah never showing
remorse for killing hamilton hamilton
meanwhile was widely mourned especially
in new york city his funeral on july the
14th was the largest in the city's long
history every business in new york was
closed that day and so many people
marched in the funeral procession that
it took hours to complete not everyone
was sorry to see hamilton die though his
two longtime political antagonists john
adams and thomas jefferson lived two
decades after hamilton's death and their
long-standing grievances against the man
made their way into their writings that
were published for posterity hamilton
wasn't around to defend himself or write
his memoirs explaining what he did and
why which surely would have been a
masterpiece of literature it has only
been recently that hamilton's reputation
has undergone a re-evaluation most
particularly through a widely successful
broadway musical based on hamilton's
life it's remarkable how accurate
alexander hamilton's predictions about
the american economy were hamilton
believed that commerce was the key to
the new country's future he predicted
the industrial revolution the rise of
manufacturing to replace farming the
primacy of cities over rural areas the
power of stock trading and banking and
the national debt in short it's
everything that makes modern capitalism
function equally important every
president after george washington has
built on the power of the executive
branch first proposed by alexander
hamilton the united states has a robust
federal government that keeps the many
states bound together precisely because
men like hamilton believed that this was
the only way to keep the country from
inevitably splitting itself apart
whether you think the legacy he left
makes him a hero or a villain you have
to admit that few of the founding
fathers achieved more than he did few
other americans have ever started as
lowly as he did and risen as high and
the tragedy of his life is that we'll
never know what else he might have been
able to achieve had he not been cut down
in his prime
[Music]
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]